[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale en 26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de ce jeudi 11
octobre 11e édition pour les universités
des mairies elle était organisée hier
par l'umih 78 pyramide de port marly et
gérard larcher valérie pécresse y ont
notamment assisté
l'occasion pour les maires présents
d'échanger des bonnes idées de trouver
aussi des solutions clés en main pour
mener à bien des projets dans leur
commune les personnes âgées sensibilisés
à la sécurité routière hier à maurepas
c'était dans le cadre de la semaine
bleue intercommunal proposé en
collaboration avec l encours et
coignières plusieurs ateliers pratiques
pour les plus de 65 ans une population
particulièrement touchés par la
mortalité sur les routes
et puis amélie nothomb à la rencontre de
ses fans la romancière était en dédicace
ce mercredi à la librairie le pavé du
canal à montigny le bretonneux à de
nombreux civils et noir ont fait le
déplacement
et puis dans ce journal deux invités
anne baekeland de l'institut de
promotion de la santé de saint quentin
en yvelines pour parler du première
entrée dans village c'est ce samedi est
également annabelle doazit de
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
pour parler des animations est de la
fête de la science qui se déroule en ce
moment sur le territoire à l'union des
maires des yvelines a donc organiser sa
11e université d mairie ce mercredi à
port marly un événement annuel qui
rassemble l'ensemble des élus communaux
du département mais aussi des
représentants d'autres collectivités et
d'entreprises privées et publiques
c'est le moment de nouer des
partenariats et d'échangés aussi sur des
projets dans les communes
reportage de nicolas landry ils se sont
rassemblés le temps d'une journée les
maires yvelinois ont participé ce
mercredi 10 octobre à l'université des
mairies des yvelines des communes
urbaines et rurales des diversité de
situations mais une même inquiétude au
fil des ans on nous a retiré nos
compétences les jeunes après les autres
et on nous demande toujours
effectivement encore plus d'efforts avec
moins de moyens
je pense que c'est parce qu'il ya un
vrai malaise
un malaise par rapport au maire et par
rapport à ce que l'on vit avec tout ce
que vous savez qu'on répète
régulièrement mais aussi les charges
supplémentaires que l'on nous met sur le
dos voit les responsabilités qu'on nous
met sur le dos donc tout ça fait que eh
bien c'est nécessaire de se retrouver la
commune c'est une petite république dans
la grande et or quand tout va mal c'est
au tour du maire et des élus municipaux
que les citoyens se retrouvent les 262
municipalités yvelinoise peuvent
s'appuyer sur le soutien d'autres
collectivités comme le département ou la
région
nous sommes nos départements déterminé
quoi qu'on veuille faire à rester le
partenaire indispensable de vos communes
et d'être toujours là pour tous vos
besoins
la région intervient notamment en
investissements pour aider les mères à
concrétiser leurs projets mais dans tous
les domaines donc c'est très important
pour moi d'être au contact avec les
maires parce que c'est eux qui
connaissent les problèmes présents lors
de cet événement les partenaires privés
gestion des déchets de l'énergie ou
encore construction de logements la
possibilité notamment pour le maire de
mort pas de faire le point sur un
chantier en cours dans la zone paris
ouest ce projet d'écoquartier nous le
nom avec kaufman en grande partie c'est
une vraie mutation et donc ont échangé à
l'instant sur ce beau projet puisque le
chantier est en cours et il ya une autre
une autre parcelle qui va également muté
donc voilà c'est aussi de partager
l'avancée des dossiers et de s'assurer
que tout va bien
l'objectif étant pour la ville de
créer du logement social puisqu'il y
avait un déficit sur sa commune cette
commune également que pour accueillir
des nouveaux habitants sur maurepas et
propose un parcours résidentiel au mort
d'asia aux jeunes roubaisiens qui
avaient des difficultés à se loger dans
le parc existant ancien des moments
d'échangé de partage les merdes
yvelinois se donnent rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition et
vous pourrez retrouver prochainement sur
notre site internet l'ensemble des
interviews réalisées dans le cadre de
cette 11e université des mairies une
soirée pour découvrir l'ensemble de
l'offre de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines le principe de la
welcome party vous le voyez sur ces
images l'événement s'est déroulé ce
mardi au ski cube
transports logement culture ou encore
installations sportives avec un panel de
services diversifiés et destiné aux
salariés des entreprises des territoires
une présentation face à des dirigeants
d'entreprise ou encore des directeurs en
ressources humaines
objectif valoriser la qualité de vie à
saint quentin en yvelines des propos
recueillis par nicolas landry
moi j'ai vu des individus qui
travaillaient quasiment à 1h15 ici le
jour on leur a trouvé un logement ici
ils sont passés de mode in d'une heure
quinze donc c'est à dire 2h30
aller-retour à à 15 minutes puisque le
hasard fait il est très proche a laissé
des sept minutes et demie vous imaginez
bon vous immerger la qualité de vie que
vous retrouver et puis en même temps la
discréditer vis-à-vis de votre
entreprise vous êtes moins stressé
donc on se bat c'est un de nos objectifs
c'est d'améliorer en tout cas le temps
de transport de le réduire
entre l'habitat et et l'entreprise et
l'emploi avec les ressources humaines et
servir chaud mais on offre on a ce qu'on
appelle un welcome pack donc de donner
tous les avantages pour les salariés qui
viennent travailler à saint quentin
qu'ils aient le maximum d'avantagés le
maximum de plaisir à travailler à saint
quentin et éventuellement y vivent ils
sont de gauche et de droite trois élus
représentant les groupes d'opposition à
voisins le bretonneux olivier afonso
gens achètent irie gastaud ont mis de
côté quelques instants leurs divergences
politiques pour lancer un appel commun
dans le viseur le maire alexandra
rosetti il lui reproche de ne pas assez
les associer au travail de la
municipalité sur des dossiers importants
comme la circulation est notamment sur
la création du
voie de contournement au sud de la
commune pour 10 engorger le centre-ville
est le maire de voisins est d'ailleurs
en conflit avec celui de magny elle lie
à mot sur le sujet écoutez les propos
des trois élus d'opposition
il faut étudier le cantonnement de
voisins mais la façon dont ses
communiqués et tout à fait le site d'une
manipulation et c'est ça qui ne convient
pas parce que c'est la caractéristique
d'un manque de vision
tous les conseils municipaux devraient
pouvoir travailler sur les questions qui
concernent les décinois et nous on est
attaché à travailler à proposer des
solutions sur la circulation
on s'est mis en guerre entre guillemets
avec la mère de manille sur un projet
dont nous les élus de l'opposition nous
n'avons pas vu les piscines ne sont même
pas au contre ce projet et nous vous
proposerons un reportage la semaine
prochaine sur le conflit actuel entre le
maire de magny les hameaux et celui de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'est en ce moment
la semaine bleue intercommunal organisé
à maurepas et l'encours et coignières au
programme notamment une animation sur le
thème de la sécurité routière proposer
aux plus de 65 ans était hier à la salle
des fêtes de maurepas le taux de
mortalité chez les seniors a augmenté de
18% sur les routes yvelinoise en deux
ans une sensibilisation qui est donc
primordial regarder ce sujet de manon
varaldo la voix de michael et demi
d'euros avec l'avancée de l'âge il est
important de rappeler certaines règles
sur les dangers de la route
les seniors ont participé à divers
ateliers simulateurs de voitures
actualisation des connaissances du code
de la route gestes qui sauvent ou encore
parcours lunettes alcool on est vraiment
très mal
je n'ai pas bu je ne bois pas
régulièrement et j'avais l'impression
d'être sur un bateau des pompiers des
spécialistes de la police nationale de
la sécurité routière ont échangé avec
les seniors l'ambiance était détendue
pourtant l'enjeu était de taille
véhiculer des messages adaptés aux
seniors de plus en plus touchés la taux
de mortalité sur la route chez les
seniors a fortement augmenté dans le
département ces dernières années on est
passé à +18 % en quelques années et
surtout pour les plus de 75 ans les
responsables de la sécurité routière
souhaite sensibiliser les seniors sur
leur capacité à prévenir d'éventuelles
difficultés
on a eu beaucoup d'accidents de
seigneurs piétons sont les accidents ou
en fait un senior s'était engagé sur la
chaussée n'a pas fait attention un poids
lourd et s'est retrouvé dans l'angle
mort du poids lourds et le poids lourd
l'a écrasée du coup ça c'est un message
à faire passer effectivement dire aux
piétons pas qu'aux seniors
attention au poids lourds ils n'ont pas
les mêmes champs de vision qu'une
automobile et donc ils peuvent ne pas
vous voir quand vous êtes sur la
chaussée
cette action originale a retenu
l'attention des principaux intéressés
une cinquantaine de personnes étaient
présentes
je trouve que c'est très intéressant
parce que quand on vieillit on n'est pas
aux dernières nouvelles au point de vue
code de la route surtout au point de vue
performances ça fait du bien de se
remettre en question des informations
complémentaires sur les dangers de la
route sont à retrouver sur le site
internet de la sécurité routière et
j'accueille sur ce plateau ma première
andy thê-anh bakelants de mon soir quand
ça vous êtes chargé de projet santé
publique ali ps de saint quentin en
yvelines ni ps c'est l'institut de
promotion de la santé il organise avec
ses partenaires à cet événement c'est le
premier rentré dans village ce samedi au
domaine du mais rente ai à magny les
hameaux
alors si une journée est dédiée en
bâclant dos aux aidants qu'est ce qu'on
entend par aidant à partir de quel
moment et ont considéré comme est bon
alors c'est très difficile de
s'identifier soi même en tant qu'aidant
parce que on est souvent simplement la
femme de
mr l'enfant ce qui définit les dents
c'est en fait toutes lettres qui va
apporter un proche qui est en perte
d'autonomie en perte d'autonomie quel
qu'en soit le motif par une situation de
handicap par une maladie invalidante et
donc tout c'est cette aide qu'on apporte
au quotidien qui peut prendre la forme
d'une aide domestique d'une aide
psychologique n'a soutien moral d'une
aide aux déplacements
c'est toutes lettres qu'on apporte au
quotidien à la personne pour qu'elle
reste le plus jeune le plus longtemps
possible en autonomie si on
recontextualise un peu ce dossier d'aidé
et dans quel est le contexte alors le
contexte c'est la journée nationale des
aidants qui est positionné le 6 octobre
et pendant un mois qui suit cette
journée nationale on a la possibilité de
s'inscrire en proposant des évènements
de proximité pour les aidants qui
habitent le territoire et c'est le cas
de cette journée et pourquoi justement
proposé cette journée pourquoi
s'associer à cet événement national
parce que le thème de cette journée
nationale cette année c'est la santé
c'est l'une de nos missions aussi
d'apporter le maximum en tout cas
d'action sur le territoire en terme de
promotion de la santé de préservation la
santé donc c'est un axe fort qui
s'inscrit aussi dans un axe plus large
globale puisque vous savez que le
ministre de la santé agnès buzyn a lancé
lundi dernier le chantier sur l'un
l'autonomie et le grand âge avec des
groupes de travail de concertation et la
kz
et dans en étain fort donc c'est un
enjeu de toute façon parce qu'on sait
que la population vieillit que en 2030
2050 même on sera plus de 2 millions 52
personnes en perte d'autonomie que les
aidants seront forcément présents
également et que c'est important de les
soutenir
également on a compris c'est un enjeu
actuel alors précision ça s'adresse aux
aidants ces journées mais aussi aux
personnes aidées oui alors c'est entrer
dans village il a été construit par un
ensemble de partenaires de proximité qui
agissent sur l'accompagnement de la
perte d'autonomie donc il s'adresse
aussi bien aux personnes dites
accompagné en perte d'autonomie mais
aussi à leur entourage et dans est donc
cette journée se veut être une
parenthèse un peu dans le quotidien
justement que vivent ces personnes alors
elles ont le choix elle peut venir seul
si elles ont envie voilà de trouver des
moments de ressourcement pour elle même
mais elle peut venir aussi accompagner
parce que on a souvent le regard sur la
personne aidée de la personne qui ne
peut plus faire
or là c'est les ateliers qui vont être
proposées permettent justement de
pouvoir partager avec son proche des
activités parce qu'elles seront adaptés
à la perte d'autonomie
donc c'est aussi près donc le programme
il y aura des mini-conférences donc
voilà de de l'information aussi du
ludique vous le disiez des ateliers
proposés le sens de la journée c'est
vraiment d'offrir cette pause à la fois
autour de la convivialité du ludique de
manière à pouvoir s'offrir du temps pour
soi du temps différent de celui qui nous
prend quelquefois beaucoup de temps
justement quand on est très aidant et
c'est pour alléger un petit peu ce
quotidien que cette journée a été
proposé donc des conférences quand même
pour apporter un petit peu l'information
c'est toujours nécessaire de repartir
avec des connaissances c'est l'occasion
de rencontrer des partenaires
et puis c'est l'occasion surtout de
partager avec son procédé mais aussi
avec d'autres aidants ou de participer
seul à des ateliers autour d'eux alors
il ya de la musique et du chant
il ya du golf parce que c'était quand
même vous l'avez obtenu voilà le thème
de cette année
e
il ya aussi des activités autour de la
cuisine adaptée de la danse de la
préservation de sa santé à travers
l'activité physique
il ya énormément de choses très ludique
très conviviale un temps de restauration
qui sera partagé en deux si on le
retrouve sur le site internet de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accessible
aussi auprès de l'équipe de l'institut
de promotion de la santé dont le lien
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran juste
derrière questions pratiques pour venir
il faut s'inscrire où on peut venir
directement à l'entrée est libre on n'a
pas voulu apporter de la contrainte à
des aidants qui en ont déjà beaucoup
donc l'idée c'est de venir au moment où
on se sent disponibles où on a envie
les personnes seront accueillies tout au
long de la journée par le ps mais aussi
par par ses partenaires qui ont
construit la journée et puis certains
ateliers demande l'inscription mais on
le fera au fur et à mesure merci à ma
cliente d'avoir été avec nous c'est un
prix je rappelle que ce premier rentré
dans village se déroule samedi entre 10h
et 17h c'est au domaine du maire en tête
à magny les hameaux
le prix goncourt est l'un des plus
prestigieux prix littéraire en france
cette distinction se décline aussi à
destination des lycéens depuis 1988 des
élèves âgés de 15 à 18 ans lisent et
étudie les ouvrages sélectionnés cette
année une classe de seconde du lycée de
la plaine de neauphle attrape fait
partie du jury mélanie poké et marylène
iapichino
15 euros non plus de 4000 pages à lire
en deux mois cette seconde du lycée de
la plaine de neauphle ne chôme pas
depuis la rentrée elle participe au prix
goncourt des lycéens avec leur
professeur de lettres
pour une fois la lecture ça sort du
cadre scolaire de la lecture analytique
de lecture linéaire des commentaires
proposés tout ça c'est autre chose
l'idée c'est de ses de retrouver une
forme de liberté par rapport au livre
parce que parce que souvent il est vécue
dans la scolarité comme étant une forme
de contrainte
le 15 novembre un lauréat recevra le
prix avant il faut lire découvert de
nouvelles techniques des lectures et
échanges avec leurs professeurs et
organisations de l'emploi du temps puis
sur ton mercredi après midi parce qu'on
a on n'a pas cours le samedi aussi les
dimanches du cousin promet week end et
c'est pas grave c'est qu'on aura fini
bon on sera content je me suis relié
avec eux mon nom mon camarade en groupe
de deux ans on dit ben 10 livres les
quinze livres ton lit pas comme si on
lisait un livre normalement en fait on y
vite et on saute d on peut sauter des
paragraphes ou des passages d'une des
pages pour les aider dans leurs choix
les 30 trappistes ont pu rencontrer les
auteurs durant une journée sur paris ils
ont pu poser des questions lors de
conférences d'enrichir ma culture déjà
le savoir aussi du coup quand je lis un
lit je me poserai différentes questions
des questions que j'ai pas forcé que me
suis pas forcément posée avant j'ai
trouvé ça intéressant parce qu'on
pouvait voir leurs esprits en fait ce
qu'ils pensaient vraiment en écrivant
leurs livres et c'était intéressant
djoko ça n'a rien à voir avec les
rencontres avec les adultes ils sont
beaucoup plus spontanée
et avec des éléments encore un mois de
lectures avant de devoir faire un choix
avec le prix goncourt des lycéens
certains élèves ont renforcé leur amour
de la lecture d'autres n'ont découvert
jusqu'au 20 octobre c'est la fête de la
science
ateliers conférences spectacles au
programme à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
exemple l'exposition corps mouvement et
innovation à la commanderie et il
encourt mélanie s'est rendu sur place
pour nous la faire découvrir le récit de
marie line à pishin haut pour la fête de
la science la commanderie a décidé de
nous parler du corps sous toutes ses
coutures
l'exposition réalisée par l'atelier des
sciences de saint quentin en yvelines
vous propose d'être acteur d exploration
du corps humain il y a une grande
tablette tactile qui s'appelle le profil
aux scop qui propose un dialogue avec
une anthropologue un dialogue virtuel
avec une anthropologue qui vous permet
de constituer le profil biologique d'un
squelette il y a également une
exploration à la loupe du corps humain
pour découvrir des anecdotes sur le
corps humain
on propose également une exploration
mathématiques où le public est invité à
se mesurer sur toutes ses coutures et
pourquoi pas étudier la divine
proportions une exploration
microscopique avec un microscope
en réalité virtuelle la deuxième partie
n'est pas de tout repos et permet de
découvrir le mouvement
quant à la troisième elle nous plonge
dans le futur il nous parle innovations
dans le domaine de la mobilité et de la
motricité avec par exemple la
présentation d'une maquette
d'exosquelette ce n'est pas juste pour
les enfants mais les enfants apprécient
cette exposition et les adultes aussi on
a justement essayer d'apporter à la fois
des connaissances pour les adultes est
aussi une découverte plus ludique pour
les enfants
l'exposition est proposée à la
commanderie dès l'âge de 6 ans jusqu'au
25 novembre et je ne l'avais pas précisé
les images de ce sujet sont signés
mélanie poquet pour continuer de parler
de cette fête de la science une nouvelle
invitée m'a rejoint à la belle doazit
bonsoir soit vous êtes chargé de
communication pour l'observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
alors l'eau vs qu organise également de
nom
animations à l'occasion de cette fête de
la science en quelques mots je sais que
c'est compliqué mais sur quels domaines
travail loveth eu à l'observatoire à
trois laboratoires
il y en a un premier qui travaille sur
l'adaptation des populations aux
changements climatiques en zone arctique
un laboratoire qui travaillent sur le
climat sur la recherche sur le
changement climatique est impliqué dans
le giec
et puis un laboratoire de spatiale voilà
qui a impliqué dans des missions
spatiales d'envergure internationale
pourquoi s'associer à chaque année à la
fête de la science pourquoi c'est
important pour le véhicule c'est très
important pour plein de raisons j'ai
envie de vous dire que la première c'est
notre répondre à notre mission de
service public en fait c'est une fête
nationale qui nous permet d'ouvrir nos
portes
je pense qu'on doit on doit ça au public
aux enfants aux adultes aux familles
voilà c'est très important pour nous
c'est aussi de rencontrer les hommes et
les femmes qui composent ce monde de la
science qui le font vivre
absolument pour les scolaires là on voit
là pendant trois jours on retrouve à peu
près mille cents scolaires et on voit
que peut-être on peut susciter des
vocations voilà que oui oui tout à fait
oui vous avez cuisse et scolaires ces
mille scolaires ce sera accueilli sur
colère la super pole mais jusqu'à demain
inclus
à l'occasion de cette fête de la science
alors au programme alo psq samedi il y
aura des expériences des manipulations
qui seront proposés pour les 6 12 ans
que pourront-ils faire alors les 6 12
ans vont pouvoir fabriquer une fusée à
eau et puis la danse et faire un jeu
vidéo sur une fabrication de fusées sa
mise en orbite plein plein de choses
visiter le jardin partagé
une mission qui causent les ballons
voilà yen il ya huit ateliers en tout
qui vont pouvoir visiter
donc ça c'est ce samedi il y aura
également une grande journée portes
ouvertes ce dimanche de 10h à 18h30 le
programme est très chargé il ya dix huit
ateliers qui seront proposées tout au
long de la journée qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on pourra découvrir alors
bas parmi les dix-huit je peux pas vous
voulez détailler tous évidemment il ya
des choses qui concerne le climat le
climat en arctique
il ya le jardin partagé de
l'observatoire il ya deux missions
spatiales qui concerne
un de nos laboratoires on a c est faux
ce qui est une collaboration franco
chinoise le satellite va partir dans une
dizaine de jours et donc
l'observatoire est impliqué dans une
partie de la mission donc on a une
maquette et puis les scientifiques sont
sur place donc les eu le public pourra
les rencontrer
voilà on a également une mission
importante qui s'appelle fébus qui est
embarqué à bord de la mission bepi
colombo qui va décoller à bord d'ariane
la semaine prochaine le 19 ou le 20 et
donc nous avons également une maquette
trois scientifiques sur place voilà qui
vont pouvoir parler de leur métier
parler de la mission est d'une manière
très ludique en fait un programme qui
européens ces dames qui européen
exactement important de l'homme elle
précisé oui ça veut dire que l'aube et
est-ce qu collaborent sur des gros
projets ça c'est aussi la vie tout à
fait oui ok dont le dire la nasa les ah
oui bien sûr pour ce qui concerne les
missions spatiales ouais t'as fait
toutes ces animations elles sont elles
sont sur inscription commence alors pour
samedi
comme ce sont des ateliers qui sont
dédiés aux 6 12 il faut réserver auprès
de moi
en revanche pour la journée de dimanche
on est porte ouverte de 10 heures à 18
heures c'est pas la peine de réserver ou
vous accueille sur place et puis on vous
on pourra pas visiter les dix huit
ateliers mais là le public va faire un
choix et on pourra les orienter ça va se
dérouler tout au long de la journée ces
ateliers tout au long de la journée
exactement il n'y a plus qu'à venir nous
voir et appuyé à choisir son parcours
c'est quoi les objectifs finalement
c'est qu'on vous connaissent mieux
voilà quels sont les objectifs pourquoi
accueillir ce public oui c'est ça c'est
aussi être un peu bien ancrée dans notre
territoire dans le territoire de la
casse qui voilà bien montrer ce qu'on
fait permettre aux habitants qui sont
pas toujours au courant de ce qui se
passe près de chez eux ça me paraît
intéressant et puis voir aussi un peu
plus loin il ya des gens qui viennent de
plus loin
ouais tout à fait démocratiser aussi un
peu la science la rendre plus accessible
pouvoir expliquer pouvoir rencontrer des
chercheurs c'est un métier dont on
connaît pas forcément tous les aspects
donc ça permet aussi de les rencontrer
les chercheurs les scientifiques les
ingénieurs ça permet de susciter des
vocations voilà ça permet de faire plein
de choses et tout ce programme de la
fête de la science a lobé est ce qu on
le retrouve sur le site internet
officiel de la fête de la science
exactement www.fetedelascience.fr et on
est sur le site national
et tout y est qui s'affiche en bas
d'écran il suffit de taper 1 sur le site
national ovs q
ton sur l'ensemble voilà vous avez plein
de moteurs différents ils vont vous
trouverez sans problème ensemble des
animations bien merci annabelle doazit
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle vous
êtes chargé de communication à
l'observatoire versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui organise donc à
l'occasion de cette fête de la science
de nombreuses animations
sachez pour être complet sur ce sujet de
la fête de la science qu une large page
sera est dédiée à cet événement dans le
7-8 loisirs qui est présenté par
marylène iapichino c'est à suivre juste
après ce journal mais avant de vous
laisser elle est toujours à la tête des
meilleures ventes littéraires la
romancière amélie nothomb aime aller à
la rencontre de ses lecteurs
hier mercredi elle était en dédicace à
la librairie du pavé du canal à montigny
le bretonneux
de nombreux fans avaient fait le
déplacement pour l'occasion marie lehn
iapichino et mélanie poquet après
l'émotion du livre l'émotion de la
rencontre amélie nothomb écrit un livre
par an depuis 1992 des romans toujours
très attendu par ses fans
cette vendéenne fait ses études à
l'université versailles saint quentin
elle attendait de rencontrer son auteur
préféré depuis longtemps pour l'occasion
elle lui a même écrit une lettre
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
touchant elle prend le temps de
comprendre de nous appeler par nos
prénoms ça se voit que c'est pas du tout
mécanique
c'est vraiment une très belle personne
qui est fait de très beau livre donc
pour tous ceux qui la connaissent pas il
faut connaître a mis les notes sont tous
apprécient son univers original et son
écriture soignée ils étaient nombreux à
patienter pour une dédicace et quelques
minutes des changes avec l'auteur tout
d'abord c'est parfaitement écrit on voit
qu'il maîtrise parfaitement la langue
française a pas fait des études de file
de loger pour rien et puis
ans est un pur bonheur les super elle
est adorable elle est très très proches
visiblement de ses lecteurs et c'est
très agréable
une rencontre tout aussi apprécié de
l'autre côté de la table
amélie nothomb et est parvenu à saint
quentin en yvelines depuis trois ans
elle ya trouvé un accueil très
chaleureux
vous savez quand on écrit et quand on
écrit au degré où j'écris on est
terriblement seul forcément et on ne
sait pas si ce qu'on écrit à un sens et
on sait encore moins qui se cachent de
l'autre côté du papier alors le moment
où on découvre c'est le moment de vérité
maintenant c'est le moment on découvre
qu'ils se cachent de l'autre côté du
papier croyez moi c'est bouleversant son
dernier roman les prénoms dépit scène
est sorti le 22 août dernier et s'est
classé directement en tête des ventes de
la rentrée littéraire c'est la fin de ce
set 8 journal cette édition et
l'ensemble de ces reportages sont à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 demain
vendredi vous retrouverez wilfried richy
à la présentation à du 7-8 l'hebdo c'est
une émission pour revenir sur l'ensemble
de l'actualité yvelinoise de la semaine
et nous on se retrouve dès lundi pour
une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale avec td 60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]